hello and welcome this is mostly weekly
and I'm vigorously and routine and this
week we're gonna talk about sports the
time we all gather around to watch a
muscular stranger put a regulation-size
ball in a specific location
I love the sports my favorite sports
team is the Denver lemons but even a
die-hard sports person like me knows
publicly-funded sports are over
boundaries I just mean that sports
bravado is driving up taxes and tuitions
and killing local economies how let's
play the balls Sports mania drives up
taxes through stadiums Major League
Soccer is adding two new teams to the
league and major US cities are bidding
to get them but much like a YouTube
comments argument it's more costly to
win please subscribe to us on YouTube
the winner will likely have to pay two
hundred million dollars for a stadium
and the winner is the US taxpayer most
of whom think MLS is a genetic disorder
but just listen to these local
politicians talk about it world-class
stadium and contribute to the economy
within the city and the state and
stadiums will cure cancer and be filled
with candy and bring grandma back to
life but every issue has two sides here
are the pros and cons of stadium
subsidies as I see them debated ton
taxpayers will cover at least half of a
200 million dollar stadiums plus
maintenance bonus ports con stadiums
literally only benefit sports fans
non-sports fans or nerds get no return
on their tax dollars programs sports con
Major League Soccer is a Ponzi scheme
it's been losing money every year but
the estimated valuation has increased
fourfold since 2008 pros so remember if
you build it they will come
pletely destroy your economy Sports
mania drives up tuition costs college
football season starts this weekend you
know what that means
it means universities are going to
continue subsidizing their athletic
programs
Rutgers for instance charges a thousand
dollars in student fees are about 8% of
total tuition to subsidize their sports
teams other schools charge as high as
twenty three percent of their total
tuition to subsidize their athletic
programs how do they get away with it
they bury it deep within the student
fees
most school athletic programs cost the
university money in 2010 Division one
schools spent over 91 thousand dollars
per student athlete that's seven times
the amount they spent on regular non
athlete students well at least those
lucky student athletes are making Bank
is that little get paid okay
right well at least those lucky student
athletes are graduating in droves only
55 percent graduate really what's that I
don't have an earpiece Sports mania
depresses economies Los Angeles was just
chosen as the site of the 2028 Olympics
which is great news for that guy who
still owns a vuvuzela Los Angeles has
already pledged to spend five billion
dollars don't worry the anticipated
revenue is six billion to be split
evenly with the International Olympic
Committee but what's a net loss of two
billion dollars between friends and this
is assuming that the games will really
only cost five billion dollars when it
costs twenty billion in London and forty
billion in Beijing saying the Olympics
will only cost five billion dollars is
like in sports you know what a hockey
lineman is like I'm totally gonna wicket
that
and then when it act when push comes to
shove ice just look at the ruins of
Athens no not those ruins these ruins
that's just 10 years after the 2004
Summer Games and now most of the
facilities have been abandoned and in
general sports franchises have a
negative impact on per-capita income so
Sports mania drives up tuition and taxes
and depresses local economies how do we
fix it by getting passionate about
fiscal responsibility I know it looks
bad out there the economics are bleak
but you've got to go out with clear eyes
balance checkbooks love in your hearts
and I love I mean cash by hearts I mean
accounts I may not know much I'm just a
recovering alcoholic former athlete cut
up a back story trying to get his kids
back but under this you've got to have
cash to spend
you got to think about the future to
have a future money's gonna save you you
got to save money you got to talk in one
order then reverse the order your time
and get out there and stop spending
taxpayer money go go go
I'm coaching thanks for watching
[Applause]
[Music]